por eso, en Khan Academy nos esforzamos por
crear un aprendizaje personalizado basado en el dominio
que transforme la
mentalidad de los estudiantes y, dentro de eso, creo que
hay tres cosas que hacen que nuestra
propuesta de valor sea única. La primera es que nuestro
contenido se proporciona de forma gratuita para
maestros y estudiantes. La segunda.  es que
tenemos contenido personalizado que está alineado con los
estándares en diferentes países, por lo que en
Brasil para el B NCC o en los EE. UU.
al Common Core y la tercera es que
somos una tecnología que no es solo un
sustituto del papel y el lápiz y no
es un cambio tan dramático que sería
abrumador y tendrías que repensar
todo en tu salón de clases pero justo
en el medio para  ofrecen un
cambio innovador que no es demasiado abrumador para los
maestros, por
lo que para nosotros en Khan Academy el dominio del
aprendizaje es bastante simple: los
incentivos para que las decisiones en clase
se tomen en función de lo que los estudiantes están
demostrando que entienden de manera constante y,
en muchos casos, eso sucede en las pruebas.
tal vez no hasta el final de su prueba, pero
creemos que debería ser un proceso de un año completo
hasta ese punto,
realmente no es como un sí o un no, ¿está completamente
basado en el dominio o no es en absoluto una
carrera de dominio? Hay un espectro de formas en que
usted  puede cambiar su salón de clases para que se base
más en el dominio en lo que respecta a la
personalización, aunque hay algunas
cosas que son realmente importantes, la
primera es que existe el contenido adecuado
para el estudio  y eso podría no ser el
mismo para todos los estudiantes en la clase y
podemos ayudar a personalizar ese contenido, pero
al final del día, es el maestro el
que será más efectivo para
personalizar el contenido usando Khan
Academy y, en segundo lugar, es autodidacta.  ritmo de modo
que si necesito más práctica en un tema determinado
, puedo tenerlo. Puedo tener lo que a
veces llamamos una cantidad funcionalmente infinita
de práctica. No lo estás consiguiendo.
Inténtalo de nuevo. No
hay problema
.  todos esperamos
tener tanto para nosotros como para nuestros
estudiantes. Creo que es un estudiante que
cree firmemente en su propio potencial
y tiene las estrategias de aprendizaje para
comprender realmente el material difícil
y, por lo tanto, hay algunas maneras en que tratamos de
habilitar esa mentalidad para los estudiantes en  nuestra
plataforma, la primera es eliminar todas las
barreras para el aprendizaje, de modo que haya
contenido accesible para todos los estudiantes en
todo momento y luego haya apoyo
mientras practica si se atasca,
etc.  no hay excusa para no comenzar a
aprender y no persistir cuando, cuando
estás atascado, el enfoque está en ti en
el segundo, aunque son procesos para
despegarse por falta de una palabra mejor, ¿verdad
? Entonces estás en medio del aprendizaje
y tú.  está atascado, lo cual está totalmente
bien, es normal, le sucede a todos, pero
justo debajo de la práctica, dirá si
está atascado, obtenga ayuda, hay varias
formas en las que podría necesitar ayuda, tal vez
necesite una pista, tal vez necesite ver un
video, tal vez deba preguntar.  tu maestro,
pero al pasar por ese proceso,
descubres cuándo es el momento adecuado para usar
cada uno de esos estrés
y luego el tercero es a través del
estímulo que brindamos en el sitio,
ya sea que estés tratando los problemas bien o
mal, lo que refuerza el mensaje de
que es  el esfuerzo que cuenta
para que la agencia de los estudiantes sea un tema muy popular en
este momento en la educación y creo
que a veces hay un error de
que va de ninguna agencia a una
agencia total, pero realmente lo vemos como un
espectro y más  Khan Academy, como
mínimo, la agencia que creemos que es
importante que los estudiantes tengan
sería responder algunas preguntas como:
¿estoy bien encaminado para completar estas tareas, en qué
orden voy a trabajar en ellas y
cuándo sé si necesito ayuda pero  a medida que
empiezas a mostrar más madurez siendo capaz
de controlar un poco más el
proceso de aprendizaje, entonces puedes empezar a
tomar decisiones más importantes como cuál es
mi objetivo real para esta semana o este
mes o todo el año escolar lo
que me importa y  cuando termine con
este contenido, ¿hay otros temas
que quiero explorar por mi cuenta
que ni siquiera son necesarios? Entonces, la
experiencia de aprendizaje en Khan Academy podría
ser diferente de un estudiante a otro. Me
gusta pensar en la experiencia de un estudiante.
en particular, su nombre es Damien, tiene
11 años y vive en el sur de California,
Los Ángeles, pero creo que su experiencia
podría ser típica de los estudiantes en Sao
Paulo o en cualquier parte del mundo.
Hubo algunas cosas sobre él.  s experiencia
que creo que fue realmente importante y
que quité de la
experiencia ideal en Khan Academy, así que la primera
es que tenía una meta muy clara para
el año que su maestro le había
proporcionado en Khan Academy y cada vez
que iniciaba sesión  lo primero que vio fue
su progreso hacia ese gran objetivo, pero
combinado con ese gran objetivo cada día
mientras practicaba, tuvo un apoyo muy detallado,
tanto el apoyo instructivo a
través de los videos y artículos, como
el apoyo de práctica a través de los
ejercicios, desafíos y pruebas unitarias.
y no solo eso, sino que también tenía a su
maestro allí como recurso si los
recursos de instrucción no eran
suficientes y estaba esta combinación de que
su maestro, la señorita Chu, era un experto
en cómo usar Khan Academy, pero también
Damien tenía algo de libertad y elección.
y agencia para seguir adelante si iba
a tener su propia libertad para elegir en
qué iba a trabajar ese día para que ese
equilibrio entre el maestro realmente
pueda  o guiar a Damien hacia el
material correcto al tener también libertad y
control sobre su proceso de aprendizaje para
que tenga el objetivo principal y el
apoyo detallado y tenga al maestro como
el experto pero los estudiantes aún tienen
la libertad y eso es lo que yo hago  piensa qué
hace que la experiencia de aprendizaje sea distinta
en Khan Academy
[Música]